so if you go on Tick Tock you may have
concerns about the state of the American
economy there are a lot of young
white-collar employees marketing majors
from Davidson
filming themselves at work
and it turns out they don't do a lot
they take a lot of breaks
we're not being mean these are their
words here's a Twitter employee from San
Francisco
welcome to a day in my life as a Twitter
employee so this past week went to SF
for the first time at a Twitter office
badged in honestly took a moment to just
soak everything in what a blessing also
started my morning off with an iced
matcha from the perch then I had a
meeting so it's quickly scheduled one of
these little pod rooms which were so
cool they're literally noise canceling
took my meeting got ready for a bunch
look how delicious this food looks oh my
goodness I was so overwhelmed then made
my way down to this Log Cabin area I
don't know what this is but it was
really cool I played some food smell
with my friends to kind of unwind a bit
um also found this really cool
meditation room Mike Rowe has spent his
life reporting on work and in fact
working he saw he saw uh that segment
and reached out and said it's more
important than ever to show the fact
that a lot of Americans are doing real
work in fact he's got a whole show about
this called Dirty Jobs it's been in the
air for 20 years he's also the host of
how America works on Fox Nation he joins
us tonight micro thanks so much for
coming on when we did that segment I
thought of you banging out the script
the whole time this is the opposite of
the kind of actual work micro has
dedicated his life to telling the rest
of us about
yeah you didn't tell me you were going
to do that segment had I known I would
have insisted on following it up with
something so thank you for the chance to
do that now of course and let me just
say I can't speak really for anybody but
me but I would bet big that millions and
millions of people jumped out of their
chairs screamed words we can't repeat on
your program as a result of watching
what you showed them and look again it's
not about being mean but our
relationship with work our definition of
what a good job is that's something we
can control and you're you're so right
for Trails of work shift with time and I
think part of the reason Dirty Jobs has
been on the air for the last 20 years is
we are the antidote to what you just
what you just showed America we we go to
places where there's no meditation room
there's there's no five-star breakfast
to start the day there's there's the bag
house at the asphalt plant they're
they're just example after example after
example 350 jobs we've done so far of
people who are still doing things that
look like work so we can talk about a
ton of different things but
fundamentally our country still needs to
be reminded of what
forgive me I'm just going to say it what
real work
looks like
well it's just interesting that what
you're calling real work
is provably real because it's the work
that if people stop doing we would all
pay for immediately like we would die in
a lot of cases there's no just be like
the this is the actual indispensable
work
look and it it it makes us angry to be
reminded of that because we don't like
the idea that we're so Reliant and so
dependent on such a small and
marginalized chunk of our Workforce but
it's the truth look this episode's about
good news so let me give you some micro
Works my Foundation evolved out of Dirty
Jobs 15 years ago with your help and a
lot of appearances on your show over the
last however many years we've raised
over six million dollars in work ethic
scholarships and we've awarded that
money to over 1500 people who are now
welding and steam fitting and pipe
fitting and plumbing and they're
thriving Tucker again and again and
again we see that it's still possible to
achieve something that looks like
Prosperity If You Begin by mastering a
skill that's in demand Shameless plugs
we're going to do it again next month
work ethic scholarships at
microworks.org we're moving the needle
in a modest way but it starts Parts by
tapping the country on the shoulder as
you have done and reminding them that
real Jobs still exist 11 million of them
are out there right now the
opportunities are everywhere don't let
anybody tell you otherwise and they
should have higher status I mean I love
what you said about these are
marginalized people that's exactly right
these are the people the guys work at
asphalt plants who make it possible for
us to travel
are marginalized and that should not be
the case and thank you for everything
you're doing to change that
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight